Це відео зняли на Чернігівщині:
матір кидається на вчительку і б’є її, аби примусити йти на батьківські збори.
А це Київ: батько учня вирішив помститися вчителю фізкультури та жорстоко побив його через те,
що він накричав на його сина.
Шоковані й обурені вчителі вийшли на вулицю з акцією протесту
і вимагають від держави захисту від агресивних школярів та їхніх батьків.
До них приєдналися колеги з інших київських шкіл.
Я глибоко обурений цим вчинком батьків!
І не тільки цим, а всіма іншими до того вчинками батьків!
Тому що сьогодні вчителя опускають на найнижчий ступінь нашого суспільства.
Абсолютно без якогось авторитету, мовляв, головним в школі має бути учень, а за ним - учитель.
Дуже часто ми стикаємося з булінгом щодо вчителів.
Найчастіше, звісно, з боку учнів,
тому що вони можуть дозволити на сьогоднішній день говорити якісь неприємні речі,
заважати іншим дітям на уроці, батьки можуть обговорювати вчителів,
можуть наговорювати,  якось сперечатися.
Така ситуація, на думку вчителів, склалася через не завжди правильне розуміння батьками
сенсу нового закону про освіту.
Він став краще захищати дітей від можливих зловживань у школі.
Це добре, кажуть вчителі, але той же закон, на їхню думку,
суттєво обмежує їхні права, прописуючи лише їхні обов’язки.
Насправді ж і батьки, і вчителі мають зрозуміти, що мета у них однакова:
виховання, навчання і захист дітей,
каже співголова громадської організації "Батьки SOS" Олена Бондаренко.
І новий закон про освіту чітко гарантує як дітям, так і вчителям захист від насилля.
Адже вчителі теж вдаються до крику, цькувань, агресії.
Експертка показує нам ось цю пояснювальну записку одного з учителів,
який зізнається в тому, що вдарив учня, але не хоче називати причини.
При цьому досі працює в школі.
На думку експертки, потрібен цілком новий підхід у вихованні на рівні не лише шкіл,
але й суспільства загалом.
Це держава повинна багато років пояснювати своїм громадянам і змінювати установки,
які є в кожного з нас із дитинства: що дати по шиї малій дитині - це взагалі нічого страшного,
а ремінь - це взагалі, мовляв, так і треба.
У нас з таким переконанням живе більшість населення, що в цьому немає нічого страшного.
І це треба ламати.
Треба ламати і системне замовчування проблем у школі і з боку вчителів, і з боку батьків.
Адже, вважає експертка, у більшості випадків будь-який серйозний конфлікт у школі є ознакою того,
що між учасниками конфлікту вже давно щось не так.
І оце "щось не так" просто вчасно не помітили або не захотіли помічати.
Рано чи пізно все одно не буде ніяких ґрат, щоб захистити вчителя від дітей і батьків.
Не буде ніяких окремих законів,  де скажуть, що "за косий погляд на вчителя - в тюрму".
Все одно доведеться домовлятися,  доведеться відкриватися і батькам, і вчителям.
На жаль, далеко не всі батьки і вчителі готові до такого діалогу,
вважають батьки школярів, які прийшли підтримати вчительську акцію проти насильства.
Батьки вважають, що всі їм винні. Але це не так.
Ми дещо винні і вчителям.
Я вважаю, що всі проблеми мають вирішуватися переговорами.
Якщо є конфлікт, то, напевно, в першу чергу треба звертатися до директора,
якось вирішувати все це, документувати, створювати прецедент.
За певним алгоритмом діяти.
Ці алгоритми захисту на всі випадки життя міносвіти не може дати школам.
Але ніхто не заважає школам самостійно розробити такі собі кодекси поведінки.
Аби не виникало нових випадків насильства,
"Батьки SOS" радять учителям разом з батьками запровадити свої правила:
що є для них неприпустимим, як на це реагувати та як вирішувати конфліктні ситуації.
Тоді агресії стане менше, а толерантності, взаємоповаги та взаєморозуміння більше.